- C'est la seule façon que
je suis capable de boire... fait
que... ou de manger.
C'est pas super génial.
- Stéphanie doit se nourri
à l'aide d'une seringue depuis
quelques jours. Elle ne peut
plus sortir du lit tellement
elle a été rouée de coups
par son ex-conjoint.
STÉPHANIE SPÉNARD, mère
victime de violence conjugale
- Ce soir-là, il a voulu coucher
avec moi. Je lui ai dit non.
Là, il a pogné les nerfs,
t'sais. Je lui ai dit :
"Regarde, t'sais, on n'est plus
ensemble. Tu es encore ici
mais on n'est plus ensemble."
- Il refusait de quitter
la maison alors qu'elle avait
mis fin à la relation
au mois de juillet.
- Il m'a prise, mais il m'a
virée comme... Il m'a prise
dans ses bras, m'envers.
J'avais les jambes dans l'air.
C'est là qu'il m'a "pitchée"
à terre, tête première.
- Il l'a ensuiteuis
étranglée. Quand elle a repris
ses esprits, elle l'a entendu
qui montait à l'étage vers la
chambre de leurs deux garç deux.
- Lui, il pensait qu'il venait
de me tuer, là. Il montait
en haut pour faire quoi
avec l, tu penses?
Il n'avait plus rien à perdre.
- Elle lui a alors fait croire
qu'elle avait tout oublié.
joué la comédie,
si bien que son ex-conjoint
a appelé la police pour dire
qu'elle s'était blessée
ême, ce qui s'est
retourné contre lui.
CHANTAL SPÉNARD
mère de Stéphanie Spénard- Quan,
mon amour", il m'a vue,
il m'a serrée fort, il m'a dit :
"Ah, mamie t'es là!" J'ai dit :
"Il faut s'en venir chez m
- La police a appelé à son tour
la mère de Stéphanie en pleine
nuit pour qu'elle vienne
chercher les enfants.
Elle est allée vle
à l'hôpital le lendemain.
- Puis quand je l'ai vue,
bien là, mon coeur voulait...
excusez, exploser.
- Avec le nez et la mâchoirefrat
méconnaissable.
Son ex-conjoint est détenu.
Il fait face à quatre chefs
d'accusation, dont tentative
de meurtre.
- Prends ça.
- Stéphanie se repose maintenant
chez sa mère et des amis
ont lancé une campagne
de sociofinancement pour l'aides
pendant ce temps.
Pourquoi vous avez accepté
avec Stéphanie de témoigner
aujourd'hui, pourquoi c'est
important pour vous?
- Parce qu'il faut que
ça arrête. Ça aurait pu être
le 19e féminicide, hein.
On était rendu à 18.
- Il n'avait jamais été violent,
mais ça aurait été bien que
si j'aurais pu me rentre compte
avant qu'il y avait un risque,
que c'était pas juste
des paroles, peut-être que
ce serait pas arrivé.
- Elle invite les autres
à ne pas fermer les yeux.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.